[Music]
all right you just saw the president
gave a rousing speech in Nashville
Tennessee during a campaign push for
Senate candidate friend of the show
Marsha Blackburn ahead of the midterm
elections we're gonna play you some of
the best moments of this rally
throughout the show but first as the
president's historic talks now with Kim
jong-un weigh in the balance now despite
what you are hearing from the left-wing
media in this country we have full
reason to believe and be hopeful about
the potential upcoming talks with North
Korea tomorrow the Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo he is said to meet with a
high-ranking North Korean official in
New York City now the most senior
official to visit the United States in
nearly two decades a massive development
and only the latest sign that these
historic talks might still take place in
Singapore they're scheduled to begin on
June the 12th now of course last week
President Trump initially canceled the
summit sending a strongly worded letter
to Kim jong-un after the despot the
dictator authorized a series of
aggressive statements and failed to
comply with the some of the basic
planning ahead of the talks and as you
can imagine your corrupt media use that
letter to trash the president revealing
what I have been saying so many times on
this program they in order to have the
president fail that means the country
has to fail they're openly rooting for
the president to fail even for more
peaceful world is at stake for our
children
watch this pathetic despicable display
of trump derangement syndrome as a
friend of mine said in an email to me as
I was on the train to New York it sounds
like a 13 year old stream of
consciousness in a breakup letter from
overnight camp break up with you before
you break up but by the way call me last
week a u.s. team in Singapore stood up
on a date by North Korea then ghosted by
North Korea they're not even responding
to u.s. overtures and today of course
culminating in name-calling a very
awkward breakup letter oh and by the way
the threat of using nuclear weapons as
far as we know he didn't consult with
his own National Security Council he
dictates this bizarre actually
embarrassing letters is a total breakup
letter and you
like this when your relationship starts
souring but you want to be the one to
break up first so you cut it off you're
kind of like maybe we can leave it
open-ended that's what this feels like
breakup letter how many times have I
said that everyone in the media they're
all sheep and they got this little
little echo chamber and they all quote
themselves and they all think they're so
smart all right so while the media is
quick to bash the president during every
twist and turn and what is a negotiation
they need to learn the art of the deal
with North Korea well they're more than
happy to ignore the president's historic
diplomatic triumphs now this includes
Trump's success so far he has freed
seventeen Americans who were once
detained or held hostage abroad the
latest example came this weekend when
the Trump administration secured the
release of an American joshua holt and
his wife after they'd spent nearly two
years in a venezuelan prison after being
detained on several bogus politically
motivated charges
take a look I'm just overwhelmed with
gratitude for you guys for everything
that you've done for the support of my
wife through those two years they were
very very very difficult three years
just so grateful for what you guys have
done and for thinking about me and and
caring about me just a normal person so
it really touches me and thank you I've
been very brave actually you've been
incredibly really so what was happening
inside of that prison so you really have
been very very brave think hard our
fellow Americans are home more on the
president's historic diplomatic gains
around the world throughout the program
tonight first we have more disturbing
developments from Robert Muller's
illegitimate runaway witch-hunt this
needs to go away last week we first
reported that the Justice Department
under the Obama administration utilized
at least one FBI informant to actively
spy on multiple people that are
associated with the Trump campaign that
includes Sam Clovis and Carter Paige
they will be here tonight along with
George papadopolis who recently played
guilty to lying to the FBI after
pressure from the office of the Special
Counsel now Sam Clovis recently told
Byron York that the informant FBI spy
used him in order to secure the meeting
with Papadopoulos meanwhile
former Trump campaign aide Michael
Caputo he also all three of these guys
that were approached by the spy will
join us tonight and of course Caputo's
claiming that he was approached by
multiple government informants during
the 2016 election imagine for a second
if there was spies and Hillary's
campaign and she did do a deal for
Russian propaganda take a look let me
tell you something that I know for a
fact the this informant this person that
they planted tried to plant into the
campaign and even into the
administration if you believe Axios he's
not the only person that came at the
campaign and the FBI is not the only
Obama agency that came at the campaign I
know because they came at me and I'm
looking for clearance to my attorney to
reveal this to the public this is just
the beginning now even former assistant
US attorney from the Southern District
of New York Andy McCarthy he's backing
up some of these claims in an article
entitled the Obama administration's
hypocritical pretext for spying on the
Trump campaign and in the article
McCarthy writes quote the Obama
administration decided to use its
counterintelligence powers to spy on the
Trump campaign using at least one covert
informant electronic monitoring of
communications and other intelligence
gathering tactics it ignored the norm
against deploying such tactics against
political opponents not based on
evidence of a trump Russia criminal
conspiracy but on speculation about the
Trump campaigns Russia contacts and
Russian third sympathies how many times
have I said their weaponizing the
powerful tools of intelligence now of
course this elicits this unprecedented
spying is now being used by team Muller
to malign President Trump and everybody
else around him hours ago the president
raised another pressing concern
surrounding the ongoing Muller
witch-hunt he tweeted out quote the 13
angry Democrats plus people who work
eight years for Obama worked on the rig
Russian witch-hunt will be meddling with
the midterm elections especially now
that Republicans stay tough are taking
the lead in the polls
there was no collusion except by the
Democrats now the president raises an
important concern especially given the
new revelation surrounding what the
president is calling
rightly Spygate and of course the
mainstream media they are providing
cover for team Muller as they actively
are rooting for the Special Counsel
investigation to find something to find
anything on this president and as you
could probably imagine the media has
been doing everything in its power to
downplay what is the single biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in
American politics in history and by the
way you have an administration using the
Justice Department to spy on an opposing
political party during a presidential
election using bought and paid for the
other campaign in this case Hillary
Clinton using her bought and paid for
funneled money through a law firm to
fusion GPS to hire a foreign national to
get Russian lies that even he says in an
interrogatory in Great Britain maybe
50/50 at best raw intelligence to then
get a warrant by lying to a spy a FISA
judge in an original application and
three subsequent applications and not
telling any of the judges that Hillary
paid for it take a look at how the
biased press is trying to brush aside
this huge massive national abuse of
power corruption scandal have inversion
to the youth use of the word spy but
let's just for the sake of discussion
use that term which conventionally means
the use of tradecraft using a formally
trained case officer who would mask
identity who would attempt to recruit so
none of the classical attributes of a
spy craft if I can use that term we're
present here this is the most benign
form of information gathering so to
characterize it as a spy or spy gate is
of course part of the narrative and it's
directly integral to what I actually
said various times Trump has seemed
attracted to conspiracy theories there's
the obvious a much more marked ponton
looseness with the truth and and and the
lies etcetera etc but these these the
the obsession with conspiracy theories
and tall tales as you say Joe dates back
for a long time I think the point right
now though is that he's using them to a
particular kind of political effect
hyoomans a liberal hack and clapper
isn't all
liar we'll get a much more on the spying
scandal and the complicit media's
cover-up all throughout the show now
let's turn to a story that left many on
the left totally embarrassed over the
weekend remember this picture circulated
online showing many illegal immigrants
being detained in a chain-link age and
of course many on the Left became
outraged just outraged quickly accusing
the Trump administration of massive
human rights violations
you have activist Shawn King said that
children of immigrants being held in
cages like dogs and Linda Sarsour
remember her oh yeah she's chimed in
hashtagging
we are our children what's in sore King
and yes your friends and the media
failed to realize is let's put those
pictures back up those pictures were
taken in 2014
Barack Hussein Obama was your president
and back then they vote zero they voice
zero concern about Obama's detention
policies now meanwhile others on the
Left use these photos of course to
attack president from whoopsie-daisy
take a look as the President correctly
points out the photo is from 2014
but that tweet highlights just how
heated this whole discussion has become
surrounding parents and children who
crossed the border some renewed scrutiny
that some children are being separated
from their parents at the border it is a
policy the Trump administration has
defended President Trump tweeted about
one of his favorite topics this morning
immigration this as his policies are
facing major criticism writing in part
quote Dems must agree to wall and new
border protection for good of country
bipartisan bill exclamation point the
president has been taking serious heat
for his immigration policies recently
particularly his policy of separating
families in detention there's actually a
new policy from the administration right
now to separate families these are
families who made the courageous
decision a hard decision to leave behind
everything that they had their families
their communities their belongings out
of fear to come to the United States
now finally tonight the reboot of the
sitcom Roseanne has been cancelled this
after Roseanne Barr made some really
incendiary pretty appalling comments on
Twitter about the
appearance of Obama aide Valerie Jarrett
earlier today she did apologize but the
show is now over we're gonna more
reaction later in the show